when you are ready you can drop your
towels
[Music]
i have gotten aroused while being nude
three two one go
duh i'm a pansexual i just like human
beings i think
they're hot found a new beach or a new
social gathering
i may like get aroused um because
they're just hot people like oh you guys
y'all are beautiful
it's completely natural to get aroused
whether people are naked or clothed
exactly like it doesn't really matter
like a girl could be wearing lingerie
she could be wearing booty shorts a guy
could be topless and i could get aroused
as someone who throws nude events
there's definitely been times where
people have been aroused at the event
and
they can excuse themselves but there's
never been a time where it's happened
and you know people made a big deal out
of it it's just something that comes and
goes it's a natural part of life and i
think you learned that being
naked more anyway the human body
is overly sexualized three
two one go
uh yes it is overly sexualized that's
why the average person the first thing
they think of is that it's going to be
an orgy
because people think the only time you
get naked is to have sex or shower so it
must be sex related
exactly i have an art event where we
draw naked bodies and we do figure
drawing
and when i told people everyone's like
well how are you going to stop people
from having sex
and that's kind of hard even when art
people can't see the naked body as art
sometimes
well and it's incredibly insulting if
the notion is the only
thing stopping us from having an orgy is
the fact that we're wearing clothes i
mean that is so stupid to think that
you know the crew on this if everybody
was nude here that there would be one
big sex party you're out of your mind
that's just not how it works
i perceive my body as art in fact when i
did my first
nude yoga shoe i saw my body for the
first time
in a way i had never seen it before it
gave me a new
sense of feeling beautiful seeing my
body nude
and when i want to be perceived as sexy
i use clothes because with clothing you
can be so much more sexy
so we're doing a thing called hot takes
we had our audience submit
hottest take they have and assumptions
that they have on
this group so the first one i sit with
my bare butt
on the couch we need more clarification
is it my couch or my friend's house
my friend's couch there's an etiquette
thing here there is a naturist etiquette
you should bring a towel or something
you know i have slip covers on my sofa
smart i just cut out the middleman and
only have brown furniture
nudists crave attention i have to admit
sometimes when i
go on nude hikes there's a certain
degree of getting caught that
does speak to an exhibitionist side of
me i kind of do get a kick when
someone's like
you know it's funny you know but um you
know
but also i know that i am doing it for
attention to call attention to this
thing and that makes me happy
nudists do a lot of psychedelics
i personally abstain but i'm also in a
huge art crowd
so yeah
i don't do drugs i mean i
recently had an experience with a weed
brownie and
that took me out and i was like
this is not for me okay next prompt
being naked in public should be legal
three two one go
i'd do a cartwheel if i didn't think
mike would fall off
can i keep on going can i just go all
the way over here
of course being naked in public should
be legal the more it becomes accepted
and normalized the less people would
freak out about
if you look at basic history there was a
time men couldn't be topless at the
beach
yeah that's right come on brother come
on through all society it's always like
if you go to another country right now
there are places women can't show their
face
so it's like oh my god you're showing
your face it's just a basic thing that
needs to change because it doesn't hurt
anybody it doesn't affect anybody
and if it was legal i would be naked on
the street right now
okay so um i somewhat agree because i
also know that not everyone wants to see
someone you know naked in public because
that may not be to their liking i have a
counter to that
that's how some people feel when maybe a
really big girl is wearing super booty
shorts but that's her choice to wear it
and
people will tell her like i don't want
to see that and that's not fair because
you can just look
away if you don't want to see it no
one's telling you you need to stand
there and stare or make an opinion about
it
um well yeah it's just because you know
it will just make like a huge like
uproar i think there should be certain
spaces for people to be naked in public
and you know just for certain spaces for
just regular people just to wear you
know boring ass clothes
it doesn't need to be illegal everywhere
because
going down the financial district you
know it does make not make any sense
i agree but i mean like that's the same
thing for all people who are fighting
for their rights to do something
there's gay bars that get shot up does
that mean that gay people should just
have a space where they should just be
gay only in this space because it's
offensive to somebody and they decided
to shoot people
so i'm just saying that like what you're
saying i really do understand it
but it's kind of like a fear-based
thought to me yes i think right is right
what makes you think it's right for you
to have the basic human right to be the
way you were born
well what i'm trying to say is that like
what you may think
is right for you it may not be right for
other people as well
that's why they don't have to
participate exactly like the whole
concept of legality just means that
you're not going to get in trouble
for being nude like in my country i
cannot do that like i could get arrested
we're not forcing everybody to be naked
we're just giving people the freedom
to be naked if they want to be naked it
is appropriate to be
nude among children and minors three
two one go
i belong to strictly family
naturist groups there is also a
background
check that is made that you pay for
that's what helps makes it
wholesome for me that's why i somewhat
agree but
obviously public nudity where it's not a
community then i can see where it can
cross a line i have done
like the world naked but bike ride and
there's you know hundreds of tourists
and i'm aware of of parents that are
suddenly
caught off guard all these naked people
on a bike they'll take their kids
and they'll put their hands in front of
their eyes or kind of move them like
this
because in that situation it's kind of
being put upon them
involuntarily well it's either shameful
or it isn't we are nudists and it is not
a sexual event and as far as world naked
bike ride or any parade or
protest or any of these events do you
know what happens when when the naked
bodies go by the kids
they giggle they laugh they point it's
fun it's silly
it's it's nothing traumatizing and i
wish i had been born and raised in a
nudist family but i didn't discover
until i was in college
i agree 100 because kids
they don't have that experience of sexes
yet like i
teach kids yoga and i have a calendar in
my studio sharing my nude art
the kids look and they continue doing
what they're doing they're not staring
at it
thinking oh this is what she's showing
oh my god look at my teacher her boobs
are there like
they're so innocent and it's beautiful
so i feel like it shouldn't be hidden
from kids because as you said it is
completely
non-sexual i love that you do that
that's super beautiful and really
amazing
i also have naked posters in my room and
when my niece comes over she goes
you know and she'll actually ask me like
can i take off my clothes
you know and i'm like yeah totally and i
feel like a lot of
kids miss out on this ability to respect
themselves and understand their body and
love themselves because there's no one
else around them who is also just
walking around in their skin and feeling
comfortable and seeing ourselves for who
we are
i'm comfortable with anybody seeing me
nude
three two one go
my naked body's already internet first i
was kind of scared but then i was like
you know
i'll just say [ __ ] it i mean my
confidence a whole lot stronger to me
it's like i don't care
you see me naked i feel like you're just
seeing the real me the true me
you know yeah so um i've seen nudist
friends of mine
have pictures taken and put on dirty you
know
vulgar websites oh i saw you on that
site so you must support that thing
no i really don't i agree with you i
mean i had a super
bad experience where i was just coming
out sharing my nude art on instagram and
then
like people started messaging me and
saying that they're seeing my photos
on pornhub and i'm like what like that
was completely without my consent
i mean for me i haven't only fans and
with those platforms
i am holding the power on
what they're able to see yes maybe they
can screenshot it yes maybe they can
share it on something else but
at least i know that i am making that
conscious decision that i want to share
that
that's who i am that's what i do and
that is my lifestyle
in the past i have been afraid to show
my body
three two one go
i didn't even know it existed when i was
a kid when i was in high school i didn't
even think about that kind of stuff but
when i went to college
i had people who'd pose nude from art
classes and immediately it was a bucket
list thing where i was like oh that's a
thing i can do
and so i signed up i did it and that's
when i was like oh this is great
and i got known as kind of like the
naked guy on campus like i was naked at
my dorm
i would go to people's rooms and they
would have a picture of me that they had
drawn me i'm like hey that's me
and people would recognize me and it was
it was fun it was silly it was goofy i
i wish everybody had that mm-hmm um
in high school in the locker rooms i
would go into a bathroom stall
instead of changing in front of the
other geyser because i was just afraid
of how they would like you know see my
body and like you know judge me and just
view me and stuff like that
so yeah
sorry the question
i did not even know that was going to
trigger me
i was afraid to show my body before
because i have
a medical condition called
folliculitis that affects this texture
of
skin on my butt so even as a kid
when people would go to swimming pools
people had on bikinis or whatever but i
would always wear
shorts because i started seeing that
everyone's butts looked smooth and mine
didn't
so i felt something was wrong with mine
and it took me
so many years before i even had the
courage
to go and let a doctor look at it to
diagnose it
no i mean if you see my instagram you
would never think
that i had this issue but it shows that
i've come
such a long way but it's it was a
struggle before
yeah that's beautiful you're perfect the
way you are
you always were thank you
i am not bothered by what other people
think of my body
three two one go
yeah why would i care as a kid growing
up with like really bad anxiety and
stuff
even though i do show myself online
naked there's another part of me that
also think
like do they like it or are they gonna
make fun of me other people's like
opinions
will definitely get to me i have a
mirror so i know what i look like
and uh i don't really care what other
people have to say i'm a fat guy man
boobs small penis i don't care
it's my life you either love me or you
don't and
you know anybody who throws some hate my
way they're they're more saying
something about themselves
well when i first started being nude
openly
was like the first time when i saw
myself
and i was like i actually love
myself i love my body i used to think oh
i need bigger boobs
i don't i don't need to do that and why
is that so revolutionary why is this
outrageous shouldn't this be the way it
is
why why do we look so crazy saying
things that make total common sense
because we're taught to not like
ourselves and i've been thinking about
why because our society profits from our
insecurities
yes i mean plastic surgery is pretty
freaking expensive
makeup everything if everyone was happy
how many people would go out of business
yeah i think at the end of the day i'm
like 100 happy with the way that i look
and how i feel
i think yeah i do i think i look amazing
and i love it i love being who i am
right now and i've fluctuated through
different weights and i've lost weight
and gained weight and
my body's going to change and i can't
wait to get older i think that it's such
a beautiful thing yeah and not everybody
gets to do that
yeah exactly i just yeah i love bodies
in general
is officially a wrap
if you want to wear it we do have some
jubilee merch oh my god i love you
oh no these are so cute some good merch
guys yeah
thank you this is the stuff he's got
like clothes
it's like a hat anyone who's comfortable
with hugs bring it in
yeah i am sweaty yucky gross hugs that's
life
[Music]
this was everything for me like you
don't understand
you know we didn't even talk about one
of the beautiful things about being a
nudist is being able to jump in water
and come out and you don't have saggy
clothes
hanging on the whole skinny dipping
thing is amazing literally
the water would close is the worst thing
in the world to me